hi i'm sal khan founder of the khan
academy and i'm here to invite you to
participate in an exciting project that
we have around career our mission
statement as a not-for-profit is to
provide a free world-class education for
anyone anywhere and part of that is help
people navigate their careers what do
they want to major in what jobs do they
want to pursue what are the implications
on their life in terms of finance this
is part of a partnership that we're
doing with bank of america we're looking
for people in all walks of life in all
sorts of careers who are willing to be
videotaped and answer questions about
how they chose their careers the good
the bad
money questions how they budget how much
they make my name is tamelia james and
i'm a high school guidance counselor my
name is eddie i'm 26 years old and i
work as a health coach my name is emmy
kelty i'm 22 years old i work as a
business associate at an indoor vertical
farming startup my name is ana nelson
i'm 28 years old and i'm an
instructional designer at a startup so
health coach is a number of different
things depending on
the individual that we come across
it can be a motivational interviewer it
can be a exercise partner we're not like
a traditional company where i have an
immediate supervisor that i get all of
my work from so currently i make ninety
thousand dollars a year when i first
started uh as a high school guidance
counselor and i was making fifty
thousand dollars so when i
finally left graduate school i had
something like seventy 72 000 of debt if
you're interested in participating you'd
like to be on camera answering questions
about where you are in your career
questions about finance decisions that
you've made please click on the link
below and submit either a short video or
short written a piece about what you do
and why